[Música]
bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el programa de france 24 en el
que hacemos un repaso sobre qué ha
ocurrido acerca de la pandemia en
nuestro continente yo soy maría clara
calle y veamos que vamos a ver en esta
emisión
hoy haremos un repaso de qué ha pasado
en el continente en estos dos años de
pandemia y además en la consulta con el
doctor carlos eduardo pérez analizaremos
lo que el mundo ha aprendido y también
lo que ha retrocedido en materia de
salud pública a causa del brote daremos
un vistazo por los cambios que ha habido
en eeuu y es que los asesores clínicos
de florida recomendaron no vacunar
contra el kobe 19 a los niños que estén
sanos esta medida contraria a los
lineamientos de los cdc además la ciudad
de nueva york- relajó algunas
restricciones en esta emisión además
conectaremos con nuestros corresponsales
es que en méxico la curva de contagios
se mantiene a la baja al igual que el
ecuador mientras que algunos estados de
brasil ya comenzaron a quitar la medida
de la más
comencemos entonces hablando de qué ha
pasado en la región durante los dos años
de la pandemia y es que el 11 de marzo
de 2020 la organización mundial de la
salud elevó a esa categoría al cob y 19
desde entonces en américa se han
confirmado más de 148 millones de
contagios según los datos de la
organización panamericana de la salud
que es la oficina de la o ms en el
continente además 2.6 millones de
personas fallecieron a causa del brote
en américa esto es más de una tercera
parte de los decesos de todo el mundo
y es que ya son más de 6 millones los
fallecimientos a causa del virus
registrados globalmente esta es la cifra
que existe dos años después de que la
organización mundial de la salud
declarara al cob y 19 como una pandemia
ariana villacorta nos hace un recuento
de que ha pasado en este tiempo
el 11 de marzo de 2020 pedrosa da nombre
jesus el director de la organización
mundial de la salud hizo un anuncio del
hecho
english outs break around the clock lado
ms ha estado evaluando este brote sin
descanso y estamos profundamente
preocupados tanto por los alarmantes
niveles de propagación y gravedad como
por los alarmantes niveles de inacción
por lo tanto hemos evaluado que el kobe
19 puede ser caracterizado como una
pandemia
nineteen canvi caracterice als pandemic
dos años después el mundo superó las 6
millones de muertes por kobe 19 de las
cuales un millón se produjeron en los
últimos 4 meses lo que significa que
alrededor de una década 1300 personas en
el mundo han fallecido a causa de este
virus
eeuu es el país que ha notificado el
mayor número de decesos seguido por
brasil e india mientras que perú es el
país con más muertes por millón de
habitantes por lo que el continente
americano es la región con más víctimas
mortales en el mundo
de 26 millones de decesos además se han
registrado más de 446 millones de
contagios a nivel global el equivalente
a una de cada 20 personas en el planeta
al douri portet que es aunque los casos
notificados y las muertes están
disminuyendo en todo el mundo y varios
países están levantando las
restricciones la pandemia está lejos de
terminar y no terminará en ninguna parte
hasta que termine en todas partes over
everywhere al lado ms también le
preocupa la reducción de pruebas que no
sólo sirven para vigilar las variantes y
la evolución de la enfermedad sino para
garantizar que las personas sepan en
dónde está el virus para que los
pacientes infectados reciban la atención
adecuada en cuanto a la vacunación lado
ms indica que más de la mitad de la
población mundial ya fue inoculada con
el esquema completo sin embargo la onu
denuncia que más de 3 mil millones de
personas siguen esperando vacunas
ellas 248 millones de personas en
latinoamérica que a pesar de ser la
región con la tasa de vacunación más
alta en el mundo hay posibilidad de que
sufra una generación perdida como
consecuencia del cob y 19 porque en la
región hemos perdido prácticamente
presencialidad escolar en torno a 56
semanas cuando un año escolar normal es
de 40 entonces realmente hay países que
no han podido continuar con la
escolaridad un estudio de la cepal
estima que alrededor de 3 millones de
niños podrían no regresar al sistema
educativo el mismo estudio reveló que un
tercio de las mujeres son víctimas de
violencia en la región y que dedican el
triple del tiempo que los hombres al
trabajo doméstico cifras que se han
exacerbado desde el inicio de la
pandemia en la medida que las mujeres se
han visto forzadas a quedarse en casa
dejando de participar en el mercado
laboral mucho más importante y para
profundizar en lo que ha ocurrido en los
dos años de pandemia saludo a esta hora
al doctor carlos eduardo pérez médico
infectólogo y nuestro asesor científico
aquí en france 24 doctor pere es un
gusto tenerlo en nuestro programa como
siempre empecemos hablando de que ha
aprendido el mundo en materia de salud
pública en estos dos años y sobre todo
que avances pero también que retrocesos
ha habido
pues hay cosas que son muy importantes
nosotros avanzamos en la ciencia las
vacunas por ejemplo que se desarrollan
en corto tiempo haber entendido la
enfermedad secuencia del virus ha
reaccionado rápidamente tal vez los más
importantes retrocesos es la inequidad
social la desigualdad en acceso supimos
que las vacunas fueron un privilegio
para unos países tenían 57 veces más la
cantidad de vacunas que para las
personas que vivían en ese país mientras
otros países no tenían ninguna yo creo
que esos dos años de una profunda
reflexión donde marcaría la vacunación y
la ciencia como lo positivo la
desigualdad y la accesibilidad como lo
negativo y lo que deberíamos aprender
para poder enfrentar nuevos desafíos que
seguramente se van a enfrentar muy
pronto doctor y después de este tiempo
la oms ya confirmó la existencia de
delta crol que es la variante que suma
lo que ya conocíamos de delta y omicron
explíquenos qué significa esto y qué tan
grave es realmente esta variante
digamos que estoy desesperado en todo lo
científico la recombinación de las
variantes y el de linajes es algo que
puede suceder naturalmente mientras haya
circulación viral de estos linajes puede
haber la recombinación lo que sabemos
hasta ahora la información es preliminar
es que no impactan y la severidad ni la
forma de transmisión y que las vacunas
que tenemos disponibles y neutralizando
esta variante sabemos que con la dieta
funciona muy bien algunas económicas
pero con esta variante parece que
funcionan bastante bien así como algunos
sueros de neutralización entonces
realmente no es nada preocupante y es
algo esperado dentro de esta situación
de la pandemia y seguramente mientras
sea la circulación viral podrás hacer
alguna recomendación similar y uno de
los debates que se han dado en
diferentes países es que puede pasar con
la vacunación en los menores de 3 y 4
años
de hecho en eeuu existe un gran debate
sobre si las autoridades sanitarias van
a aprobar o no el biológico para esta
población explíquenos por qué es tan
difícil desarrollar una vacuna para
estos menores de estos años que le
cuento y cuáles son los que ellos
enfrentaría
recordemos que la vacunación para hacer
ensayos clínicos inicialmente se tiene
que hacer un consentimiento informado se
hace en población adulta se explicar las
diferentes escenarios que se puede hacer
ante experimentar pero cuando se hace
con menores de edad pues tiene unas
implicaciones éticas mucho más grandes
las poblaciones son más reducidas las
monitoras más estrecha y obviamente
entre la población sea infante menor
pues mayor
cuidado y precisiones que tengan los
estudios clínicos la demora de más
porque no se conozca con un funcional
biológico tiene que ver con la
dosificación pero sobre todo con el
diseño de los estudios y como es una
enfermedad que no tiene una digamos un
desenlace fatal en la población infantil
hay otras cosas que se debe evaluar hay
información sobre lavado sobre las
vacunas en niños ya conocemos que
nuestros países por encima de tres años
y en algunos por encima de cinco años se
están vacunando población en menores de
tres años hay que ser más cautos esperar
los estudios si la dificultad radica en
el diseño de los estudios clínicos y los
desenlaces que se buscan en este
poblacional y hasta ahora en medio de lo
poco que se conoce según lo que usted no
se explica en los menores de tres años
puede haber alguna consecuencia en
materia de salud al vacunarse contra el
kobe 19 o todavía es muy pronto para
decirlo
es muy pronto para decirlo pero en
general la mayoría vacunas que reciben
los humanos antes de los 2 años de edad
donde recibimos el 70% las vacunas los
dos los biológicos yo lo que el problema
no es que impacte en la salud sino que
tanto beneficia a traer la salud en
menores de 3 años hemos visto que la
población pediátrica si sufre hoy de
algunos que tienen comorbilidades pueden
tener complicaciones y en algunos niños
pueden producir un síndrome de respuesta
inflamatoria esas evaluaciones se tienen
que mirar con la población vacunada si
se deshace desarrollando no como estamos
en una zona de bajo número de casos para
poder hacer estos estudios clínicos y
mostrar esos desenlaces se toma más
tiempo no es porque sean inseguras es
que tanto beneficio pueden hacer y
también la problema de la dosificación
que es dosis son necesarias para
producir la inmunidad doctor y ahora
hablemos del sub linaje llamado bea
punto 2 que es una derivación por
decirlo así de la variante omicron y es
que en francia está causando
preocupación pues response es
responsable de más del 38 por ciento de
los nuevos contagios que se han
reportado en estos dos años de pandemia
hemos visto que en américa latina'
ocurre algo similar de lo que vemos en
otros países europeos solo que unos
meses después en ese sentido podríamos
esperar un aumento del bea punto 2 en
américa latina' o no
es probablemente que estas variantes
circulen y la la lo importante de esto
es entender que mientras haya personas
que no se hayan vacunado va a haber
circulación viral y mientras haya
circulación viral sea el país que sea
puede haber diseminación de este tipo de
linajes y sus linajes en este su linaje
es como una variante que se ha visto que
expande pero nuevamente en personas no
vacunadas es mucho más importante que
las personas que están vacunadas y es
muy importante es vacunas con refuerzo y
donde realmente la infección no parece
que tenga ninguna trascendencia entonces
es muy importante reconocer que estas
variantes van a ser noticias cada dos
semanas 48 semanas porque van a ver unas
circulaciones hasta cuándo vamos a
frenar estas circulaciones cuando todos
nos hayamos vacunado y todo no quiere
decir un país una ciudad o una un
territorio todo el planeta porque
necesitamos que la inmunización no sea
solamente sectorizada sino sea global
porque si no nos vacunamos todos todos
podemos ser susceptibles a una variante
un futuro que espero que eso no suceda
pero puede ser una amenaza mientras la
gente no se haya vacunado en todo el
mundo y así como durante la pandemia
hemos evidenciado la facilidad con la
que se pueden reproducir nuevos linajes
del coi 19 también hemos aprendido
algunas de las secuelas que deja este
virus en quienes lo padecen y una de
ellas es que algunas personas han
reportado dolores en las manos y en los
pies después de padecer el brote a qué
se debe esto
de claras son muchas muchas las
situaciones este es un digamos un
síntoma llamativo ese dolor de piernas
pero tenemos muchas otras complicaciones
de lo que llamamos con el prolongado o
lonko bit que puede suceder hasta en el
30 personas de las personas del 30 por
ciento de los pacientes que han tenido
un hobbit y estos se dan manifestaciones
neurológicas cardiovasculares pulmonares
y esta manifestación neurológica del
dolor de las piernas y las manos
concomitantemente parece que es un daño
en el nervio periférico que todavía no
tenemos establecido cómo tratarlo pero
sí es muy llamativo nos llama también la
atención profundamente las alteraciones
neurológicas alteraciones en la memoria
en la concentración que se ha visto cada
vez con los pacientes todas están muy
temprano si faltaran los años para
entender qué son las secuelas de kobe
pero ya hay gran varios grupos de
estudio de tratar de desarrollar como
diagnosticarlo y cómo poderlo enfrentar
y otro de los posibles síntomas
secundarios del cobi 19 es la niebla
mental previamente explíquenos en qué
consiste esto
es cuando hay una inflamación que lo que
genera el virus no solamente se inflaman
los pulmones sino el corazón y el
cerebro también entonces en esos
episodios que se llaman de encefalitis o
de la inflamación cerebral al parecer
algunas desconexiones en las
motoneuronas superiores es donde las
personas tienen algunas pérdidas de
memoria alteraciones de la concentración
ya hemos visto y lo he visto en mi
práctica que hay pacientes que superan
el coi bastante bien desde su punto de
vista físico o cardiovascular y pulmonar
pero alteraciones neurológicas como por
ejemplo que se olvidan algunas cosas que
no se contentan algunas no recuerdan por
ejemplo un idioma extranjero y hay
particularidades estamos tratando
entender qué es lo que pasó en qué
grupos de personas y sobre todo cómo
poder rehabilitar para poderlo hacer
este periodo de niebla mental parece que
es una secuela de ese daño cerebral
antes inflamación cerebral que no
suceden todos es ocasional pero si
sucede en algunos pacientes que antes de
ojo es sintomático esperaremos entonces
que revelan estos estudios que venga
gracias doctor por estar con nosotros
como les decíamos estos son algunos de
los conocimientos que ha develado la
ciencia en los dos años de pandemia pero
ahora existe un reto adicional
especialmente en ucrania pues además del
cobi 19 el país enfrenta una guerra que
puede repercutir negativamente en la
situación sanitaria y es que allí ya
está escaseando el oxígeno y de hecho
algunos centros hospitalarios están
siendo atacados veamos el siguiente
reporte para entender las nuevas
dificultades que el conflicto trae para
la pandemia en ucrania y en los países
vecinos
la guerra con rusia ha provocado una
crisis sanitaria en ucrania según la
organización mundial de la salud que
prevé una eventual propagación de cobb
en 19 entre la población ya que sólo un
tercio de los más de 44 millones de
habitantes de este país se había
inoculado con el esquema completo hasta
el inicio del conflicto algo que puede
repercutir en el continente europeo dado
que más de 2 millones de ucranianos han
huido de su país la mayoría a polonia
eslovaquia rumanía moldavia y hungría
the worst of the news las condiciones
que vemos en ucrania son los peores
ingredientes posibles para la
amplificación y la propagación de
enfermedades infecciosas si se pone a
tanta gente desesperada en movimiento
mujeres y niños apiñados gente en
sótanos y gente estresada gente que no
come que no duerme es estas son las
condiciones en las que los sistemas
inmunológicos son débiles las defensas
de la gente son bajas y las enfermedades
infecciosas pueden arrasar con la
población de esta manera
los lakers a esto se suma el número de
muertes y destrucción provocadas por los
combates
la organización mundial de la salud ha
confirmado que desde el inicio de la
invasión rusa el 24 de febrero al menos
10 personas han muerto y varias más han
resultado heridas en 18 ataques contra
instalaciones sanitarias en territorio
ucraniano incluido un ataque aéreo
contra un hospital de maternidad en la
ciudad de mariupol cifras que podrían
aumentar dado que unas mil instalaciones
sanitarias entre hospitales y
dispensarios están situadas a menos de
10 kilómetros de la línea del frente
desde el punto de vista de la salud esta
crisis sólo puede empeorar a menos que
se produzca un movimiento inmediato para
el cese de hostilidades dentro de
ucrania y en la real situación de la
única solución real a la situación es la
paz la oms se sigue pidiendo a la
federación de rusia que se comprometa a
resolver esta crisis de forma pacífica y
que permita el acceso seguro y sin
trabas a la ayuda humanitaria para los
necesitan mantener en asistentes for 2
en it
lado ms ya envió 500 concentradores de
oxígeno a ucrania sin embargo advierte
que las muertes relacionadas al kobe 19
aumentarán en la medida que continúe la
escasez de oxígeno y después de este
panorama en ucrania volvamos a hablar de
nuestra región en ecuador la noticia
relacionada con el kobe 19 es que la
cantidad de contagios sigue bajando al
igual que el número de personas
hospitalizadas a causa del brote vamos
entonces a quito dónde está nuestro
corresponsal
gustavo correa hola gustado y bienvenido
a nuestro programa empecemos hablando de
la situación epidémica actual de ecuador
y porque los casos están bajando tanto
hola que tal un saludo manera clara
efectivamente ecuador registra una
tendencia a la baja inclusive después
del feriado de carnaval calificado como
uno de los periodos más seguros por el
ministerio de la salud la tendencia de
contagio de kobe 19 continúa a la baja
en ecuador y eso se ve reflejado una
menor ocupación hospitalaria menor
demanda de consultas médicas atenciones
de emergencia y demanda de camas
seguridades de cuidados intensivos según
cifras oficiales del órgano de salud del
país el nivel de ocupación de camas para
hospitalización es el 15 por ciento y el
32 por ciento de camas y unidades de
cuidados intensivos
a nivel nacional inclusive muchos
hospitales ya reportan cero casos de
hospitalización por 19 el número de
casos positivos en el año 2022 se redujo
en 83.588
el número de fallecimientos también bajó
de 188 a principios de año pasando a 7
en el mes en curso y finalmente la
positividad se registra en 14% tanto en
pruebas de antígeno como en pruebas de
pcr en el país el 99 por ciento de los
casos positivos corresponden a la
variante omicron y el 0,5 por ciento la
variante delta según la titular de salud
del país ximena garzón
en las próximas semanas la variante
delta desaparezca del país
gustavo y ahora hablemos de la
vacunación porque hay varias novedades
en el país y es que las noticias van
desde la aplicación de una cuarta dosis
de refuerzo hasta el comienzo del
esquema en los menores entre 3 y 4 años
cuéntenos cuál es el panorama
sin ego de 88% de la población ya cuenta
con la primera dosis el 85% cuenta con
la segunda dosis y 30% con la dosis de
refuerzo a partir del mes de mayo de
este año ecuador iniciará la vacunación
de cuartas voces en principio con un
personal de salud y personas vulnerables
en este sentido la inauguración ya está
disponible para todas las personas y se
han acelerado los programas de
vacunación para hacer frente a la
pandemia 19 también se inició la
aplicación de fármacos y adolescentes de
2 a 17 años de edad que pueden recibir
las dosis de refuerzo y el requerimiento
es que hayan cumplido 6 meses de aplicar
la segunda dosis paralelamente desde el
21 de febrero a los niños de 34 años son
vacunados contra la cob inicio 9 en
ecuador comenzó en cuatro ciudades
principales este país se realizó
progresivamente en este grupo etario
utilizando lagunas y novak y desde el 21
de febrero se extendió a nivel nacional
en 28 días se aplicará la segunda dosis
en esta población se realiza en conjunto
con el ministerio de salud con brigadas
médicas que visitan las escuelas con
autorización de los padres o los
representantes de los niños para además
los padres también pueden llevar a sus
niños al centro de salud para contar así
con el firewall contra la cob y 19 y
antes de esa reducción de casos de la
que usted nos hablaban el gobierno ha
decidido poner a varias ciudades en
verde en su esquema de semaforización
qué implica esto
si las principales ciudades del país
cambia en su alerta epidemiológica y
pasa en el color verde o nivel 1 es el
caso de la capital ecuatoriana a quito y
la ciudad costera de guayaquil esto se
traduce en un incremento de aforos en
las actividades no esenciales y
establecimientos religiosos espectáculos
públicos y actividades básicas a partir
de esta semana la asistencia en lugares
de entretenimiento se incrementa en un
promedio del 80 al 100 por ciento
aproximadamente mientras que en
espectáculos públicos se incrementa al
cien por ciento en exteriores a partir
de este momento asistir a centros
comerciales supermercados ferias de
comidas o entidades bancarias se
realizará con el 100% de aforo otra
medida muy esperada es el uso de la
mascarilla que con la reducción de casos
y el cambio alerta a verde se permite la
práctica deportiva en canchas en
exteriores sin la mascarilla cumpliendo
con algunos requerimientos como tener el
ciclo de vacunación completo y presentar
el carnet de vacunación según la titular
de salud de continuar la tendencia a la
baja y alcanzar el nivel de contagio al
5% por podría al fin luego de dos años
abandonar la mascarilla después de
durante todo este tipo de pandemia en
principio en exteriores es la medida más
esperada anunciando por las autoridades
que podría declararse entre los meses de
abril o mayo gustavo ortega gracias por
toda esta información y brevemente les
presentamos otras noticias destacadas de
la semana en nuestro continente
comenzamos este recorrido en colombia
porque la farmacéutica estadounidense
merck empezó a vender su píldora molt no
pura beer en las farmacias del país esto
llega a menos de dos semanas después de
que la autoridad colombiana de
medicamentos el invima aprobara su uso
de emergencia la pastilla solo puede
comprarse teniendo una prescripción
médica y se receta para ciertos
pacientes previamente les cuento que el
63 8% de los municipios de guatemala
están en alerta roja por la pandemia la
semaforización implica que en esta
máxima alerta
los estudiantes no asistan
presencialmente a las escuelas públicas
al menos durante las próximas dos
semanas y todavía no es hora de relajar
las medidas en américa así lo advirtió
la ms al decir que el continente aún es
vulnerable ante el cob y 10 y es que en
la región se confirmó más del 60 por
ciento de los nuevos casos reportados en
todo el mundo en enero y febrero según
el organismo
pero en medio de la cantidad de
contagios también avanza la vacunación
miremos las cifras que reporta la página
web our world in day time en canadá más
del 81% de la población ya cuenta con el
esquema completo de vacunación contra el
cob y 19 en panamá este porcentaje es de
poco más de la mitad de los habitantes
con casi 59 % mientras que en colombia
ya el 66% de las personas tienen todas
las dosis requeridas del biológico
y la vacunación es precisamente lo que
está contribuyendo a que algunos estados
de brasil levanten la obligatoriedad de
usar mascarillas como el sao paulo donde
el 90% del público objetivo ya tiene el
esquema completo por eso el gobierno
local anunció que allí ya no será
necesario llevar tapabocas en exteriores
para eso conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal
valeria saccone que quiere estar en sao
paulo valeria cuéntenos cómo funcionará
este relajamiento
a partir de esta semana las mascarillas
ya no son obligatorias en sanpaolo la
ciudad más grande de brasil y también la
más grande de américa latina y la más
afectada por la pandemia de el
coronavirus de momento no son
obligatorias en los espacios al aire
libre pero el 23 de marzo se hará una
nueva valoración para ver si se puede
flexibilizar su uso también en los
espacios cerrados eso sí el gobernador
su autoría ya ha avisado que en escuelas
y oficinas seguirán siendo obligatorias
además al menos 15 estados federados de
brasil han flexibilizado el uso del
tapabocas
eso sí en ciudades como río de janeiro
no se nota porque desde hace meses con
el calor del verano muchas personas
habían renunciado a utilizar este objeto
incluso en el transporte público
mientras tanto brasil ya ha superado los
654 mil muertos por el cob y 19 y qué ha
pasado con el anuncio que hizo el
presidente ya ir bolsonaro la semana
pasada que quería tratar la pandemia
como una endemia
de momento la idea de declarar la
pandemia una endemia en brasil es tan
solo eso una idea que el presidente yo
del bolsonaro está estudiando junto al
ministerio de salud según el mandatario
brasileño a los datos son alentadores y
permitirían hacer este movimiento pero
los expertos en salud se oponen y
recuerdan que la media semanal de
muertos sigue alta y sigue por encima de
los 500 muertos diarios tras unas
semanas de fuertes contagios debidos a
la llegada de la ola o micro que podría
ya haber alcanzado su pico entonces se
espera que las próximas semanas las
cosas mejoren bolsonaro ya ha dicho que
no hay una fecha concreta para este
cambio pero que podría ser muy pronto y
hay que recordar que no es el único
mandatario que quiere hacer algo
parecido en diciembre el presidente del
gobierno de españa' pedro sánchez
también anunció una medida parecida y
parece que cada vez más estados están
deseando recuperar la normalidad tras
dos años de pandemia ya miraremos si el
país da ese paso gracias valeria no sólo
en brasil se están relajando las medidas
en eeuu el país que más contagios ha
confirmado en toda la pandemia varios
gobiernos estatales optan por eliminar
el uso obligatorio de tapabocas en las
escuelas o incluso están recomendando no
vacunar contra el kobe 19 a los menores
de 3 años que gocen de buena salud aquí
les contamos lo que está ocurriendo en
el país
mientras el convoy del pueblo protesta
contra las medidas establecidas para
contener el avance del cob y 19 y
dificulta el tráfico en washington dice
florida toma una decisión que desafía a
los demócratas y a los centros para el
control y la prevención de enfermedades
de estados unidos conocidos como si mis
hijos
son el departamento de salud de florida
va a ser el primer estado en recomendar
oficialmente no vacunar a los niños
sanos con del gobi 19 aunque la medida
se basó en los estudios citados por el
cirujano general de este estado joseph
lapa 2 que mostraron pocas muertes por
covite entre niños sanos y un elevado
riesgo de efectos secundarios de la
vacuna como la miocarditis en el caso de
los niños más pequeños además nueva york
que eliminó el uso obligatorio de las
mascarillas en las escuelas y ya no se
le exigirá a los ciudadanos pruebas de
vacunación para ingresar a espacios
cerrados una decisión contradictoria a
la de las autoridades federales que van
a prorrogar un mes más el uso
obligatorio del tapabocas en los aviones
y el transporte público
algo que ha generado confusión entre los
ciudadanos
entenderla en los trenes y autobuses y
dejar que la gente se sienta en los
restaurantes en ella no tiene sentido
que va a hacer que todo el mundo se
sienta mucho más seguro y mejor al no
estar en contacto con los gérmenes y los
gérmenes de otras personas y entretanto
california lanza una campaña para
promover el empleo seguro ante el cob y
19 que consiste en jornadas educativas
sobre seguridad en los centros laborales
las bajas pagadas por la enfermedad y
las protecciones a los empleados ante
posibles represalias por parte de los
empleadores en la medida que suben a
227.000
en todo el territorio estadounidense
vamos a méxico donde hay buenas noticias
y es que la organización panamericana de
la salud afirmó que el país se acerca a
lo que llamo un periodo interés y de
mikko esto por la disminución de casos
salimos entonces con nuestro
corresponsal maria carbonell mario
explíquenos cómo es la situación de los
casos y si es tan positiva como para
declarar este periodo
así es se cumplen ya seis semanas de una
reducción constante continua de la
epidemia en méxico es una reducción del
41 por ciento respecto del pico máximo
de la segunda ola el sub-secretario hugo
lópez gatell responsable del manejo de
la epidemia ha dicho que estas
reducciones en los tres indicadores en
nuevos casos en hospitalizaciones y en
defunciones en cuanto a las
hospitalizaciones las reducciones en muy
considerables del 92% y en los
fallecimientos es de 89% incluso la
organización panamericana de la salud ha
reconocido que con estas seis semanas de
reducción continua de la epidemia méxico
está entrando ya en una fase inter
epidémica desde luego el llamado la
población es a seguirse cuidando toda
vez que en cualquier momento pudiera
darse un nuevo pico aquí en cualquier
parte del mundo por eso pues las
indicaciones continúan de cuidarse
y en medio de los cuidados el gobierno
dijo que la vacunación podría detenerse
en un 90% explíquenos a qué se debe esto
y en qué etapa de vacunación está méxico
sí de acuerdo con las cifras oficiales
del gobierno en la población general hay
una cobertura en general del 90 por
ciento es decir todos aquellos que se
han acercado a los quioscos de
vacunación buscando aplicarse la dosis
lo han logrado y el responsable de este
manejo de la epidemia ha dicho que es
probable que ahí se quede es decir que
se llegue al 90% general ahora en cuanto
a aplicación de la dosis de refuerzo o
la tercera dosis que es la etapa en la
que estamos en población mayor de 60
años hay una cobertura del 70 por ciento
de los de 40 59 años la cobertura es un
poco más bajas de 47% y ese amplio hay
que recordar a los adolescentes de 14 a
17 años en este rango de la población la
cobertura es del 53 por ciento aún no se
está vacunando a menores de 14 años
salvo aquellos que estén amparados por
la justicia o que tengan alguna
comorbilidad
gracias por estas buenas noticias mario
y terminamos nuestro programa dando un
vistazo a otra información relacionada
con la pandemia y que está destacada en
redes hablemos del salvador la unidad de
investigación del medio la prensa
gráfica comprobó que febrero fue cuando
menos vacunas contra el cob y 19 se han
aplicado en el país desde abril de 2021
y es que en ese mes se pusieron
252 mil biológicos sin embargo el
ministerio de salud respondió que el
descenso es porque quedan menos personas
por vacunar en puerto rico ya no será
obligatorio usar tapabocas en espacios
cerrados sin embargo si tienen que
portar lo quienes estén en el transporte
público o trabajen en centros de salud o
en hogares para adultos mayores y otra
de las noticias es que el laboratorio
moderna decidió no cobrar por el derecho
a desarrollar su vacuna este
relajamiento de la patente de aplicará
para países de medianos y bajos ingresos
y que hacen parte de kóvacs esto es 92
naciones
este fue nuestro resumen de lo que ha
pasado con el cob y 19 en américa esta
semana gracias por estar con nosotros
nos vemos pronto
[Música]